i would say it is traditional at this
point in the show when john bishop is on
the couch
to turn to the americans to say
understanding anything
yeah no no i'm getting it all right
oh yeah yeah good good he said he was in
the fellowship of the ring
about a picture something someone got a
picture
because talking talking of accents this
is a weird thing
so chris pratt is this this seems so
unlikely that you
have now learned how to do the voices
from towie yeah sort of yeah
we love that garbage tv back in
in the states my wife was crazy about it
and when i was
here filming guardians we shot guardians
of the galaxy here in
in london and and my wife anna came out
to visit
and she fell in love with this show
towie the only way is essex it's this
show that's like basically their jersey
shorts the jersey shore from
from here it's like this uh town
somewhere
essex i guess and
these folks are just like the worst and
it was like i'm a parrot a little bit
and so when i hear
when i hear it all the time i just
started picking it up and started like i
could pick up their accent and do their
accent a little bit
you know yeah i'm okay it's gonna sound
this is really embarrassing to do in
front of a whole room full of brits here
but i'll try it anyways
so it's like so like honestly i like i
saw this guy
honestly like michael cheated on me when
he was in a beef heart and i was like
because he's telling me he's like you
know no i miss you or whatever and i'm
like
you miss me what am i your mother
that will never be useful that would be
useful but that's very good now i want
to watch the show
i love the fact that you spent months in
england
and that's what you talk about culture
i already know this because i was told
this but uh that japanese
it's it isn't just regular japanese no
it's
not it's traditional japanese which is
so incredibly difficult to learn
but i imagine regular japanese is quite
hard yes yes
yeah i mean i i didn't realize that i
was i was being taught traditional
japanese until
um actors that came into to shoot shogun
world who spoke modern japanese
were like oh my god how are you doing
this because even for them it was quite
tricky
um but yeah it was amazing can and
can you speak it a bit now i can yeah i
can actually
i can
any idea
chris is going go did you just ask me on
a date
okay
[Laughter]
okay in
cool no what did you really say i said
let's lay down our swords and have a
dignified conversation which is more
traditional
we kind of said that backstage didn't we
yeah we said hey let's just do it that
was it
you've talked on the show before about
how you you came to stand up late and
the jobs you did
before you did it there's a weird kind
of connection between
john and chris because now was it yeah i
get my dick up on girls
[Laughter]
you were a hoover salesman yeah it was
okay so
as a hoover salesman you've talked about
this
ritual you had to go through yeah yeah i
worked for a car i was
17 something like that i would work for
a company called
a kb cleaners where you have to go in in
the morning
and sing sing before you go out to tell
try and sell vacuum cleaners to the
world yeah and it was
i think it was an american concept that
he brought over and and it was just
bizarre well you know all the sales it
was commission only so you get in this
room
all of a sudden an enthusiasm yeah yeah
i mean there was some sheets they give
you some sheets and it'd be like this is
to the tune of i want to hold you down
by the beatles and go
i want to sell a cleaner
i want to sell a
honest to god it was just like that and
you'd go in and sting and there was
always one guy he'd always
try and get into the room first because
he wanted to play the drums
it was mad because as a 17 year old
there's a suit that borrows from a
friend i thought that's what all jobs
were like
here's the weird thing chris pratt could
have been your boss
because you sort of did this what was it
coupons you were saying yeah it was
coupons yeah i did
i had the same thing i was like a
multi-level marketing salesman job and
we did a chant in the morning just to
clarify what's a coupon
a coupon is like a it's like a
certificate it's a for a promotion so we
would sell
coupons for businesses in the service
industry like a
day spa type thing a salon to like come
and you know get all uh dolled up
and and and like get your hair done and
your nails done give them the gifts
right you give them a gift
you can give them as gifts yeah but
you're giving i look for opportunities
that's what you're giving i
yeah i was it was one of those things
where if you work very hard
and you stay enthusiastic and you follow
the steps you do the chant in the
morning i mean i was
i was hook line and sinker you know you
can open your own office
and like start your own business and i
did i like made it all the way to the
top
i opened my own office at 19 i had my
own business
and um and went to a state in
colorado and i opened my own office in
denver and put an ad in the paper
the same ad that i had answered which
said you like rock and roll music you
want to make money
i know that's good it's your life
yes
you're reading this i'm getting a
off a supermodel
you're gonna live this life ring this
number and you go wow
it means it yeah it's prediction test
only interested in hiring an idiot
you answer that ad check that box
yes i do like money that's crazy and i
also like rock and roll music
quick you haven't already filled the
position have you
yes we put that same ad in the paper and
it turned out like it it wasn't all
enthusiastic 18 year olds like myself
who answered it was like the bottom of
the unemployment rate
just terrible people who would i'd send
out to sell and represent my company and
they would like
rob a place
every morning tell me how you're feeling
and we'd go
fantastic terrific great oh yeah strong
juice baby sucker i feel wonderful right
on right on right on juice
chews i feel great
i feel great let's kick some ass kick
some ass who's number one
we are who's number two who gives a
i had no idea but chris pratt
i hear i hear you are a magician
dude yes i am respect
yeah well i haven't been just a magician
like uh
like i know real magic yes no these are
not like i have the secrets yeah
well i i know some tricks it's been a
while
because these no i honestly these cards
chris didn't bring these cards
they just we got them yeah you could
give you these cards
can you do magic real magic magic yes
not a trick you have to be very careful
about practicing in the dark arts
lots of flourishes um okay okay here we
go
now it's been a while so i screw this up
just you know you'll cut it out um yeah
this is a whole new deck
i haven't seen this deck you haven't
shown me this deck
you know uh this is a deck
of cards captivated yet
okay so i'm gonna shuffle it i also
played a magician
in the movie the magnificent seven i saw
that thank you
you like movies and uh and
so i learned i got to practice a little
bit there okay i need um
a volunteer should i oh all right i got
will i am this is awesome i'm doing a
card trick for will i am i love my life
um okay so here's what we're gonna do
this is called burnham
and it works fifty percent of the time
so i'm gonna make three piles should i
just
now will i am may i call you will i am
okay hell yeah um
take this card and pick it up and put it
on actually no put it on either side of
these
piles you want face up this card right
here oh
take that card take that card and put it
face up on either side oh yeah i get to
choose
yeah yeah yeah and now take that card
and put it put it there face up
hell yeah now this is your card
but do not let me see it but show uh
everybody
okay that's your card but let me see it
okay i'll come with this
and don't say anything oh good card and
when you're and when you're finished
committing it to memory put it back in
the middle pile anywhere anywhere
inside put it anywhere you want in the
middle pile
hide it and make it so that i could
never know where you put it
okay you got it yeah boom on that just
happened
okay now two fours
i call this trick two fours
i take one four on the bottom one four
on top now what do i know i know that
your card you remember your card
don't tell me it's somewhere inside
this little deck but i don't know where
it is so i'm gonna put that in the
middle
what and put that right there now i want
you to
shuffle that four times
no i like i told you this only works
half the time so if it doesn't work
i'm going to be really embarrassed one
shuffle
two shuffles
three shuffles
in the middle you might have screwed it
up for me but that's okay
let's try now what all great magicians
say yeah
one two three four okay now i'm gonna
look
because i'm gonna find your card don't
don't don't look at my process wait wait
wait wait wait wait
how many chances you get to find the car
though cause we can sit there for
hours i guess four oh you get four
chances yep
okay that seems fair 30 minutes each
yeah this is a different
segment of the graham norton show okay
let's see here
no no that's not it oh it's coming
it's gonna be here okay hold on i think
i got it
nope okay hold on
i got four chances wait a second will
you count four chances to shuffle
through them or four chances to show him
he just no he's just looking he's
looking for your card i'm looking for
your card
okay i got it come on the first chance
dear lord god please
hell no no okay no no no
i got four chances yeah boom okay it's
called
burnham i take one i burn it i might
have burned your card
will i am your card hell no okay hold on
is this your card hell no just tell me
your card now because this could be it
what is your card you can tell me now
because i wouldn't be able to take it
out
and tell me it's an a an a of hearts a
of hearts
yeah the ace of hearts
no uh
shazam
give me a fist bump wait a second magic
fist bump
keep it right there don't move it
squeeze
that is good
you